over the past few years billions have
been invested in an industry that
promised to rival pro sports leagues but
now the Esports organizations who sought
to pave this future face a tough
Reckoning is the dream of Esports
already dying
[Music]
Giants of the Space Team Solomid and 100
thieves have terminated dozens of
positions between them others who own
teams in supposedly lucrative leagues
have sold to third parties The
consultancy Firm Deloitte expects only
about a third of European Esports teams
to turn a profit this year money seems
to be much harder to come by the problem
is that Esports teams are dependent on
Advertising they had hoped to fill
stadiums with screaming fans and secure
lucrative broadcast deals but those have
largely failed to materialize lately
about 60 percent of their revenue still
comes from advertising and sponsorships
and when the global economy slows ad
budgets are usually the first to be cut
what's more many of the advertisers were
crypto companies who've been having
their own tough time FTX the bankrupt
crypto exchange had pledged 210 million
dollars for team Solomid to change its
name to TSM FTX the deal is now on hold
finally venture capitalist interest is
cooled back in 2018 they invested about
three times more in Esports than this
year and are less willing to cover
losses much of the hype previously
dedicated to Esports is moving over to
gaming influencers who live stream
themselves on Twitch and YouTube the
cash crunch has left a slew of teams
fighting to ensure it's not game over